he is a great friend of the show and of
my wife and my whole family so I'm
always throw-in Mike Tirico joins the
Rich Eisen show hey Ben Mike I am okay I
am sorry that you are not here yeah in
Atlanta and we doin my best
all all all your neighbors and all the
folks out there in Southern California
scary to walk it is everybody's okay so
far so good certainly here today and
appreciate those those words Mike what
do you think happens tonight man I mean
huge game this evening give me your
thoughts here you said it last week I
think there in the pregame or or
postgame one of the two both last week
and this really heavyweight matchups
with in the NFC that I think will look
back it'll go a long way to determine
who ends up in what slots it and who
ends up in the playoffs you know in
Atlanta even though they're third and
they're two games back they control
their fate as of tonight if they win
every game the rest of the way they win
the NFC South and this is exactly what
they were last year at this time there
were seven and five won their last four
and got it
but the difference this time all for the
remaining games from the division that
gives the opportunity to but two of them
are against New Orleans they play a
really good team twice in eighteen days
so if you think okay can you go three
and one the last four you can't let the
one at home against New Orleans slips
this is a huge game I think for Atlanta
and for New Orleans they got the
division lead by beating Carolina you
love what both teams have very similar
good quarterbacks great combos and
running backs Atlanta's got the
difference making receiver but the
corner Lattimore for New Orleans is but
a rookie story this year young improving
defenses this is a good game when the
teams aren't good and when they're
really good this has been a great game
so that's what I think we might teach
about do you think is Lana Moore playing
best you can tell it sounds that way
which would be huge
he's only really played six snaps in the
last few weeks but every indication
during the week was they thought he'd be
close enough to play so it's gonna be
one of those six o'clock when the and
it's on that work pregame shows starts I
think that's when it starts dissidents
we keep an eye on the guys come on the
field make sure he's out there testing
it ready to go what about Ingram what do
you think we have yeah hi you know that
that's always scary when you have a
running back who's playing so what has a
toe injury
I think it's encouraging that they kept
him out of practice for a couple of days
of the toe injury but didn't declare him
out you know that that almost sounds
more like maintenance so again same deal
what's watching when he comes out and
warms up but the short week makes those
always a difficult turn for the coaches
okay now you know when you and other
play-by-play folk and Collinsworth and
other analysts meet with the coaching
staff and with the players you know
that's a lot of that's that's background
information I understand right but what
what did you glean about the Atlanta
offense when you talked to Ryan and the
rest of the crew there about what what's
going on with this offense this year
Mike you know Rick stated they thought
they were back rolling until they faced
Minnesota and that might be more a
Minnesota thing than an Atlanta thing
you know just to go back to history the
people who aren't up to speed on Steve
Sarkisian was obviously brought in as
the offensive coordinator you know the
three prior offensive coordinators
turned into head coaches around the NFL
so Matt Ryan's made some folks a lot of
money and Julio Jones as well they
didn't pick up where they left off last
year which was incredible numbers MVP
season for Ryan looked like the last
three games before Minnesota they were
rolling the point total was around 30
the open passes were they're using
Mohamed Sanu in different ways and then
they ran into Minnesota and they
couldn't convert on third down so if you
want to things to watch for tonight
Minnesota took the number one surrett
down offense in the league Atlanta and
held them to 1 of 10 and they did it
with a lot of third and seventh third
and eight Charles Davis and Kevin
Burkhardt did a great job calling the
game and Charles was on the right from
the start
third and seven thirty and six third and
seven those first three drives so watch
Atlanta getting some yardage to third
and manageable will be important and I
think the general feel was this offense
should be back where it was a couple
weeks ago not where it was on Sunday
against Mike Mike Tirico joining me here
before calling Saints Falcons on NBC NFL
Network and Amazon Prime part of the
triple cast as we like to say now this
is an unheralded if you will NFL rivalry
doesn't get a lot of juice because it's
not in the Northeast right right but I
mean you were in the building for one of
the easily the most famous game between
these two teams when the Superdome
reopened so you
a ton of these games between Falcons and
Saints what do you think of this rivalry
that that folks across the country might
not know about before they settle in for
this evening my and you know what right
now I went back to even look I think we
did this on Monday night three different
times Atlanta in the world it's kind of
it's no disrespect to the Panthers
obviously they were in the Superbowl
visit a couple years ago this is the
rivalry of the south of NFL southern
football this is the rivalry these two
have long been the big cities in the
south the emergence of Charlotte and
other cities will mitigate that in
Florida cities over time but these are
the two franchises that have been down
here for over a half century they were
bad together and they got good together
here and I think their games have been
very high-scoring I think the number is
over this decade no we've seen nine of
the 14 games they played decided by six
or less three in overtime and like I
said he had lost similarities of the
teams the fans seem to be fired up they
sound can fans like to play the Saints
and then the same deal when the this the
Falcons go down to the Georgia Dome or
two of the Superdome to play so these
teams really get the best out of each
other and Matt Ryan said it he said it
best maybe does yesterday what do you
think would you play in the Saints and
drew Brees I hope I have the ball last
because it always feels like that last
drive is win or lose and you'll like
that when guys go into a game with that
attitude so exciting and then you know
the Falcons a move on a Tampa after that
when a lot of folks are wondering about
the Tampa job so I want to ask you this
question since you have ten years of
experience that the worldwide leader
call him Monday Night Football games
many of them extra Gruden I think you
know where I'm going with this okay yes
all right now yeah and and you no longer
work at the world why later so yes let's
what do you think do you think Gruden
wants to at some point go back and baste
it in it not like you you just sitting
next to the guy I mean I've been removed
for a while and I see he still gets into
it do you think Rudin has in his mind a
certain job and a certain set of
circumstances that he would leave the
booth to go back for Mike we mean we
mean John not his son deuces the strange
it's coach Washington right he wants to
maybe coach with him you know what I
mean so at some point I've I've I've
always said this I I have no I
yeah and even when I was sitting with
John and talking to him almost every day
we still stay in touch I have no idea if
he is ready to jump back I know he's
enjoying working with Sean and with Jay
Robin and chip Dean who producing direct
Monday Night Football they they've been
a team there for nine years which Sean
do in the last two and I know John loves
that I always I thought watching games
on Sundays I laugh I'll I'll send a
picture to John I can't go through one
convert one quarter without seeing a
Groody commercial right along the way so
I think he's loving the lifestyle of it
and I think he loves being a part of
football the quarterback camp and
everything else there is something
that's always told me I've said this
even when he was sitting next to me and
I didn't want to go anywhere and I don't
want to go now I always said I just
think I just think he's a coach I think
he he would want to coach one more time
before it's done that doesn't mean 2018
would be the right time or the right
openings I have no idea what's gonna
open and I haven't talked to John about
that that's nice early but I really
think rich at some point here along the
way that John would would like to coach
one more time even though sitting next
to me and sit next to Sean is fun
winning and losing is still as you said
sitting next to mooch it it's an
appetite that can't be satiated or
satisfied by just wearing makeup and
wearing a nice suit and tie and so I
think those guys are perpetually asking
themselves do I want to go back and do
it and I think at some point John will
give it one more shot of its college I
know the pros it might be high school
that knows but I think Y at one point
he'll go back but I don't necessarily
know it's this year 64 games to go Mike
last one for you of 64 games to hell
Game one of that stretch is tonight and
it's okay just do what most everybody
did when we were back in the day at ESPN
just steal it just take it so with with
64 games to go and you have now you've
called a ton of games and you've you've
been at Sunday Night Football best team
you've laid your Tirico eyes on Steve I
know you know it's them it's New England
you just
you got you go really mean you follow
the league every week like you said when
we're doing this Thursday run work we're
to two games a week and you're seeing
every every game on Sunday like you guys
do is in Los Angeles on here and I felt
Sundays and for the Patriots you know
you're going a couple of times this year
okay who is this guy and who is this guy
and they win and all of a sudden you
look up this Patriots defense that oh my
goodness they've never given up yards
and points like this in the first month
of the season now it's ten twelve
thirteen know Patricia's beard keeps
growing and teams keep getting stopped
and they just have again everything all
the running backs they have the
receiving options that they have Brady
who looks you know he's going back were
you the one person ever going backwards
in age they just still have all the
answers I'm really interested to see
because Pittsburgh has kind of played
three games close enough just to win and
get by you can't do that against New
England that game next Sunday assuming
both get through this week which is not
easy
it's very Baltimore Sunday nights gonna
be tough New England without Gronk oh no
no Miami gets tougher can those teams
give us one of those epic regular-season
games because you get the feeling that
when it really matters in the end of
January
Pittsburgh's best chance to win is going
to be playing that championship game if
they happen in Pittsburgh so you almost
think they have to get the game in the
regular season to get the number one
seed so the head to me is the biggest of
the next 64 games that one which I
probably was is halfway through the 64
yeah next week that's right I'm looking
forward to that so do you think in
college football before I let you go
that uh Nick Saban is calling up
Syracuse to see how you beat this
Clemson team what do you think I think
we're just taking we're just taking our
lap that was about the best sign at
College GameDay when they did College
GameDay the ACC championship Syracuse is
a quality loss something to that
affected you know I will say this a lot
was made understandably Clemson's
terrific quarterback was not a hundred
percent and then got hurt in the second
half of that game
Clemson's defense was still out there
and Syracuse still scored in the 20s
they said they played they played the
best game they played in years on that
night so obviously Clemson is beatable
but man
delicious game Clemson and Alabama what
for a semi wow that's that's incredible
the the playoff noise is silly they need
to go to six teams if if four of us were
in business together we would never cut
the profits three ways for these five
conferences to have won or in this
year's case two left on the side of the
road is just nonsensical if they go to
six with the top to get a bye play three
six four or five and get down to four
and then keep the format going for the
rest of January where the dates are now
I just think every conference
championship get every conference
champion gets in and then it gives us
room for one other team whoever the best
of the rest is I think that makes the
games even more exciting but Alabama
Clemson I can't wait to watch that New
Year's Day is gonna be fun for sure Mike
I look forward to watching tonight
thanks out there you see the kids you
got it seem seem to you down there in
Atlanta Mike Tirico joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience